¿Por qué vamos a hablar hoy de Londres?
Lo cierto es que el otro día fui al
cine a ver la última película del
"Diario de Briget Jones". Sí, se lo que
estáis pensando, pero mi novia quería
ir y yo soy una persona muy obediente.
El caso es que esta película está
ambientada en Londres y hubo una cosa que me
llamó mucho la atención. Fijaros en los
rascacielos que se hagan en el fondo, esto
no estaba en la primera película de
Bridget Jones, que está rodada hace unos
diez años. Es decir si os dais cuenta el
skyline londinense ha cambiado una
barbaridad en sólo una década. Y esto
es llamativo porque no hablamos de un
país que esté en pleno crecimiento
como China o Dubái..
Así que cuando llega a casa me puse a
buscar qué había pasado en Londres
últimamente, y es flipante porque si
miramos la economía de Reino Unido en
los últimos diez años no vamos a ver
un crecimiento espectacular pero sin
embargo Londres es otro mundo,
de hecho a día de hoy ya es la cuarta
capital qué más rápido está creciendo,
casi al mismo nivel que Dubái y su
población ha crecido un 50 por ciento
en sólo 20 años.
Pensad que en un continente como Europa
donde casi todos los países están
perdiendo población
Londres ha sumado tres millones de
habitantes
así, de repente, de golpe, como por arte
de magia. En el mundo financiero
Londres es hoy en día más importante
que la mismísima Nueva York.
Preguntaréis ¿qué ha pasado en esta
ciudad?
¿cómo se explica este milagro económico?
Hoy os lo vamos a explicar
Reino Unido siempre ha sido un
país de inmigrantes y lógicamente el
principal destino de todos estos nuevos
ciudadanos es la capital,
Londres. Sin embargo, en los últimos diez
años
esta inmigración se ha disparado y esto
nos lo va a explicar Gabriel Lefelman que es
un politólogo español que lleva tres
años viviendo en esta ciudad.
- "Hola Fonseca,  pues llevo más de seis años y
está viviendo en Londres,
la verdad que el tiempo vuela. Y bueno
con la ampliación de la Unión Europea
en 2004 y 2007 hubo más de 12 países
que se unieron a la Unión Europea entre ellos
Bulgaria y Rumanía.
Eso supuso un gran movimiento migratorio
de Europa del Este hacia Reino Unido,
sobre todo desde Polonia.
Además a esto habría que añadir la inmigración
proveniente de España, Italia y Portugal
los que me encuentro yo que vinieron
después del crash de 2008 y sobre esto,
además, está toda la inmigración que
proviene de la Commonwealth que son
países como la India, Pakistán, Canadá
o Australia.
La mayor parte de los inmigrantes
europeos tienen una alta cualificación,
por ejemplo, en Londres a día de hoy en
más de un millón 600 mil empleos de
alta cualificación,
mientras que nueva york solamente
alcanzan un poquito más de 1.100.000,
de trabajos cualificados.
Esto significa que además de cubrir los
trabajos que los británicos no quieren
hacer, los inmigrantes europeos también son
contratados en trabajos de alta
cualificación y emprenden sus propios
negocios en el sector servicios como
puede ser el tecnológico o el financiero".
- "Tomás abrió su empresa de marketing
cuatro años después de llegar de
Varsovia y ahora da trabajo a seis
personas, cuatro de las cuales son
británicas".
Pero no sólo hay que ver las empresas
desde un punto de vista económico o de
creación de empleo.
El hecho de que haya gente bien formada
significa más bares, más fiestas, más
exposiciones, más eventos culturales, es
decir todas esas cosas que hacen que una
ciudad sea cool. Por ejemplo fuera del
Perú
¿Cuál sería el mejor restaurante de
comida peruana del mundo? Pues según
todas las guías gastronómicas es el
ceviche que ¿donde está? efectivamente en
la capital británica.
- "Como dice Fonseca londres tiene un atractivo
único ya que es un referente mundial en
la gastronomía, aunque resulta
sorprendente, además de serlo en la
cultura y el entretenimiento.
Bueno Londres de examen también tiene muchas cosas
que ofrecer además de tener una economía
dinámica, unas instituciones fuertes, también ofrece unos
salarios altos, eso hizo que muchos de
nosotros que viviamos en España, Italia
o Grecia eligiéramos Londres como
destino, porque además tras la crisis financiera de 2008
los mercados laborales se contrajeron mucho
por lo que muchos nos
vimos forzados a irnos si
queríamos seguir nuestra vocación".
Esto es lo que muchos economistas están
empezando a llamar ya "el efecto red"
que significa que cuanta más
gente y más empresas allá en un sitio
concreto, más incentivos hay para que entren
nuevos inmigrantes y creen más empresas
aún.
De hecho, para que os hagáis una idea, desde
el año 2010
Londres está generando una media de
1.000 startups tecnológicas cada año.
Pero esperad  porque todavía hay más.
Todos estos rascacielos
que veis aquí están concentrados en un
área que apenas ocupa poco más de un
kilómetro cuadrado. A este barrio se le
llama la City de Londres.
Es decir, que por un lado tenemos el Londres
que todos conocemos y luego está el
Londres, Londres, el Londres de verdad
que es como un país aparte dentro de
Reino Unido. De hecho, normalmente decimos que Gran
Bretaña es la unión de cuatro naciones
Inglaterra, Escocia, Gales e Irlanda del
Norte ¿verdad? Bueno, en realidad no es del
todo cierto porque habría que añadir
esta quinta que es Londres, la city
de Londres que tiene su propio alcalde y
sus propias leyes.
- "La City  es el centro financiero de Gran
Bretaña.
Alrededor de 7.000 personas viven en la
City pero cada día 300 mil acuden a
trabajar en sus bancos y empresas".
Es decir, que el alcalde de londres es este
señor que vemos aquí que se llama
Sadik-khan, pero sin embargo
el lord-alcalde de la City de Londres es este
otro que vemos aquí que se llama
Jeffrey Evans y una de las
particularidades del sistema político
del Londres, Londres es que no
solamente votan las personas residentes
sino que también tienen derecho a votar
las empresas establecidas en este lugar.
Por ejemplo, Unilever tiene su sede
fiscal en la City londinense y por eso
cuando hay elecciones
Unilever puede votar.
Y os preguntaréis ¿valdría lo mismo el voto
de Unilever que el de otras empresas más
pequeñas?
Pues no porque dependiendo del número
de trabajadores que tenga esta empresa
registrados en la City tendrán derecho
a votar más o menos veces.
Por cierto que esto tan bonita que está
sonando es la música The Forgotten Rock
un grupo de rock de Irlanda que nos ha
mandado su música.
Si os gusta buscarles en los enlaces de
la descripción.
Y os preguntareis ¿es entonces la
city un paraíso fiscal?
Pues la respuesta es que no, en Reino
Unido los impuestos son muy parecidos en
todas la regiones y concretamente el
impuesto de sociedades que es el que
afecta a las empresas es igual en todo
el país.
Ahora bien, es cierto que la city tiene
unas normas muy favorables para los
negocios. Por ejemplo, las normas de
urbanismo de la City londinense son
muchísimo más laxas que las del resto
de Londres y por eso es por lo que en
esta zona se concentran todos los
rascacielos que veíamos en la película
de Bridget Jones.
Ahora bien, la City tiene un rol mucho
más interesante que todo esto, porque
éste lord alcalde del que hablábamos
antes tiene como principal cometido
viajar por todo el mundo ofreciendo las
maravillosas ventajas que tienen Londres
para la inversión.
- "El lord alcalde viajará a Indonesia para asegurar que
Londres y Reino Unido continúan
siendo un socio preferente para
servicios financieros y profesionales".
Es decir que Londres tiene su propio
departamento de marketing para atraer a
todas las empresas del mundo.
Estados Unidos tiene en su poder
económico dividido en distintas
ciudades. Por ejemplo, la política está
en Washington dc, si lo que me interesa
es el mundo financiero te tendrías que
ir a Nueva York,
si quieres industria automoción te vas
a Detroit, si quieres entretenimiento y
tecnología te vas a Los Ángeles o San
Francisco.
Lo mismo ocurre en Alemania donde tenemos a
Berlín, Munich y Frankfurt. En españa
estaría Madrid y Barcelona. -"Mientras que
Reino Unido solamente tiene a Londres y
las demás ciudades no pueden competir
con esta megalópolis. Londres es
referente en el ámbito tecnológico,
político, económico, social, artístico,
cultural, y la moda. Eso significa que
para que os hagáis una idea, Londres
genera el 22 por ciento de la riqueza
que se genera en todo el país, que son
65 millones de personas.
Londres es una ciudad única y no sólo
por el Big Ben, los fish and chips y los
pubs. Google Mind tiene su sede aquí,
los mejores intelectuales vienen a dar
charlas y clases en las universidades
londinenses como por ejemplo la London
Economic School, el número de ciclistas se
ha triplicado por tres en los últimos
15 años. Candem tiene música de calidad
para dar y tomar.
Vamos, resumiendo, que Londres tiene
muchos atractivos".
A todo esto, hay que sumarle un factor muy
importante y es que Reino Unido siempre
ha tenido muy buenas relaciones
comerciales con Estados Unidos y esto no
es porque tengan un acuerdo de libre
comercio,
simplemente es que en los dos países
tienen el inglés como lengua materna y
eso quieras que no ayuda mucho para el
comercio.
Si a eso le sumas el hecho de ser parte
de la Unión Europea
tienes que Londres es la ciudad perfecta
para cualquier empresa estadounidense
que quiera abrir mercado en Europa.
Y la pregunta es ¿afectará el Brexit
al crecimiento de Londres? Porque una
cosa está clara: aunque una mayoría
de los británicos votará a favor de
salirse de la Unión Europea,
la inmensa mayoría de los londinenses
estaban a favor de quedarse. Y vosotros
¿qué pensáis? Podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre si alguien quiere
profundizar más en este tema
encontrará varios links en la
descripción. Si os ha gustado el video
darle a like  y no olvidéis que
publicamos nuevos vídeos todas las
semanas, así que si no queréis perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones suscribiros
si no lo habéis hecho todavía.
Nos vemos en el próximo vídeo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto